[Musique]
bonsoir des enfants mais qu'est ce que
tu as à sauter comme ça ne nous reçoit
terrible aujourd'hui aux poids lourds vu
de dos urgente et patrons comme sont en
pleine forme ce soir bruxelles où le jeu
manque d'eau allant à l'handicap de
north et ne dépense pas trop aux yeux
sans crainte
je sème tenu de son don peuvent comme
[Musique]
propagande de content de voir le petit
nom prononce en faveur du corps
qu'est ce qui ne va pas mais toujours
pas la rougeole ou au bout du couloir
c'est ça qui tracasse ton fai prends tu
auras la rousserolle j'espère bien comme
ça on s'occupera aussi noir c'est pour
toi ma petite pape rhône elle parce que
tu as été très sage
alors tiens nicolas une belle pour toi
de ton nounours car il est le plus gros
une pour moi et maintenant
enfin la rolls du rosier twitter me pape
rumble
tu ne peux pas que ça tirait pas ne nous
occupe à petit tout et puis je me
reproche allez on y va et ne marche pas
sur les pieds nos morceaux peuvent nous
envier à 4 fleure bon le loup rogemont
aussi à quatre coeurs d'une chambre de
couleurs et quand la nuit est arrivé all
the blue room
quand la nuit est d'arriver mais quatre
ferme ont dansé
[Musique]
fini de qu'après cornichons nous
d'autres champignons non d'autres
boutures ou mesdemoiselles et messieurs
le bouton de rose dans ce tout les 4
entre eux a livré dans merveilleux comme
le sommeil élevé le taux de rongeurs
cela va nous donner dans la rosée
parfait mais voilà du barbouillé pour le
reste la journée est maintenant aux
doudous ovi
voilà
pas de nuage intime nos deux mignons qui
sait oui
aux bleus dans un ami nicolas bonne
l'état prône l
[Musique]
bonne nuit mes chers petits enfants
embrasser bien fort vos parents allaient
vite au lit et faites de beaux rêves
vous voir à pattes rouges allons en
route mon gros nounours
bonne nuit à demain à tous
oh
[Musique]
on